okay so now how
how about this like uh junior year prom
okay i'm i'm uh in 11 i'm in 11th grade
dad already knows where this is going
i'm so excited for prom right and and uh
what i'm doing is i'm taking a
uh a pack of cigarettes and
uh dispensing with the cigarettes and
i'm rolling these
cone-shaped spliffs right these uh these
joints and with the cone shapes so that
every other one is upside down
so that they all fit perfectly into this
pack of cigarettes right
you love packing things yeah right and
uh
and i'm all excited i'm like and and i
got the drawer
like it's i've got the cigarette butt
open so you can see how they all fit
together great sticking out with the
twisted
you know like end and it's open
on display and in the drawer which is
also wide open
so dad for one reason or another mom
other than his mom
mom is in my room she looks in the
drawer she's looking at a box of joints
so she tells dad and uh
and you tell the story from here well
we didn't like it and so clearly
the only thing to do was to confiscate
the joints and this was oh and didn't
mom
light one to make sure it was pot i
didn't know that that may be happening
but anyway
i i got the word i got the word and so
yeah i i got a hold of the offending
substance
and this was about if i remember
correctly
three or four o'clock in the afternoon
on the day of on the day of the prom
and i you know i i just i knew you'd
spent your hard saved allowance money on
it
and i felt a little bit uncomfortable
with the economic impact
i said well shep if i give him the money
he's not going to be able to go get any
more so
i'll feel better about it and i was too
stupid i was too stupid to wait until
the next day
yeah dad's the winner you paid him back
for the joint reimbursement
we were talking about ten dollars value
no no no no no it was uh
i mean at least 20 pounds no come on
no i wouldn't use the bottom's a whole
cigarette box full of joints
well maybe we didn't get all the joints
and we only got part of it and then
thank you for partying and i think i
think
i i think i over charged
yeah oh my god well you have to take
into account the time you took to roll
the joints
it's quite an expense yeah dad dad paid
for it and within like half an hour
i love how ted you just couldn't handle
like the inefficiency of it you know
like this makes bad business sense like
we need to fix this
yeah oh yeah that was that was too much
so what you ran out gotta block a hash
and then oh yeah i
didn't have time to roll it all into
joints but i certainly
replaced the actual drugs in short order
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man
because it's gnarly and it's all the
stuff i wasn't allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats